In the current coffee industry, a coffee farmer has two big problems.
First, they lose control of their product when they sell their coffee fruit.
And afterwards, there is buying and selling between middlemen along the chain,...
...from importers and exporters to roasters.
But the farmer sees none of the revenue created by this buying and selling.
What if we connect farmers to a supply chain where a farmer is involved...
...from his crop all the way to the consumer.
Provide a revenue sharing model with fixed percentages of revenue...
...that are tied to quality and not tied to the commodities market.
With Thrive Farmers, this is now possible.
So, now it's time to do your part.
Know the story of your coffee and where it comes from.
Choose specialty grade roasters that deal directly with farmers, and spread the word.